[Music]
hi Manuel and welcome to back to
Berkeley thank you so much it's really
nice to be here it's it's really you got
this weather especially for me I I think
so you know it's not like this often so
it's really an honor to to interview you
for thank you series and so you know I
wanted to start by asking you about
about well both your current you know
research on consciousness but but also
its roots in the past you know what
motivated you to get into this yes so
yes what motivated me was the fact that
as a kid when I was six years old I was
a very dumb kid and I wanted to be
smarter and I pestered you know I was
after my father to tell me how to be
smarter and at some point after pestered
him enough he got very exasperated said
you know you should study the brain if
you understand how the brain works you
can be smarter and I thought that a
terrific idea that really set me in the
direction I wanted to go I'm very
grateful to him for that but that didn't
make me a smart kid I was still a dumb
kid for for quite a while and I remember
also when I was in so I we moved a lot
so I can pinpoint my memories by where I
was living at the time and so some
between the 3rd and the 5th grade I
remember being outside trying to think
of how the brain how my brain works it
bothered me that we don't have a manual
for driving this device and I wanted to
understand it better it's like really
introspective and the best I could do is
what came up was this idea that I later
discovered is called a homunculus this
idea that there's a small man well in
this case inside my brain that's looking
out through my eyes and it's make doing
all the thinking and I knew that this
can't be an explanation because of the
recursive nature even at that age yeah
yeah you don't have to fourth grade is
just fine for that you know you know
that that's not right you know in in
many ways this you know this this early
story it seems it seems to have been
echoed and you know anybody who was
advised by you like I was can relate to
that in the sense that you know it
always seemed like you're advising style
had had these elements where he would
they would slow us down and and then you
know it was but but at the end of that
you'd come up with some very deep inside
it you know so you have to understand
that I was still a very dumb kid and I
had to slow you down because otherwise I
couldn't understand what you were saying
and it really helped a lot that I mean
it's still the case that almost
everybody almost everybody's neurons
fire at twice the speed that mine do and
you know when I give a talk the worst
part is sometimes at the end when
somebody speaks very rapidly nothing
gets in I've in my classes somebody who
will speak and I have to ask some other
student to translate for me yeah just to
get it to the point where I can
understand what they say I you know my
memories I'd come in and I talk to you
about about some idea and you know you'd
find it you know it was you you'd be
very
you know very happy with it and then I
come in the next week and I explain the
same idea so encouraging yeah it was a
you know big just just this just this
way of keeping attention on on an idea
for a very long time until something the
next step was ready to be taken
so Mike zipser her once I heard him
explaining to somebody what it was like
to have me as an advisory he said I
would see him once a week we have a set
time he'd come in tell me an idea that
was good but then the the over the week
he didn't have any more ideas so he'd
come by and he told me the same idea and
it was still very so I actually by
thanking away from there you know you
you know that you have the reputation
for being probably the greatest advice
in theoretical computer science or maybe
all of computer science so what's what's
the see you know what are the secrets to
to advising with you you know that I'm
sort of dumbstruck here I hear hmm if I
ever find out I would let you know I I
did write this advice to a graduate
student I don't know you know maybe a
lot of it is that the students I advise
the students that I feel a rapport with
yeah close rapport I enjoy them
hopefully they enjoy me if we have that
enjoyment and of course whatever it is
we were looking at will be a pleasure
yeah I think you you once mentioned to
me the pleasure principle it's very
important to recognize these things they
give you pleasure and yeah great so so
going back to very very you know the the
start of your exploration about the
oh yes I told you about the 4th grade I
guess yeah so later when you were you
know as as you went along that this did
this follow you as you went through it's
something I've always been interested in
so when I went to MIT it was a very bad
student there just like I had always
been all my life I wanted still to be
smart and so I took a course with a
professor humanities professor named
Richard Shawn Walt who had whose PhD
thesis was on Freud and that was
something that at the time I thought
maybe that would give me some idea of
what's going on in the brain and that
was helpful
also in that he suggested I was with him
when I was a junior he suggested there's
a wonderful person here that just come
named Warren s McCulloch dr. Warren s
McCulloch and you should introduce
yourself to him so was he a young
faculty member he was probably about 60
years old in his time
long beard very thoughtful very wise he
taught me a lot really he was my mentor
really and it was just great working
with him and he was a neurophysiologist
his interest was in the brain he he's he
and his mathematical sidekick Walter
Pitts
are the ones that defined the formal
neuron mm-hmm theirs was the definition
and their theorem this was 1942-43
the theorem was that with these formal
neurons you could build build a circuit
that would be a Turing machine you could
you give it a paper tape and it would do
everything that the Turing machine does
and at that time that was pretty
interesting yeah and he was somebody you
know I haven't come from Freud he was
somebody who hated Freud
he hated for it where Freud had written
a paper called the future of an illusion
he wrote one called the past of a
delusion where he was referring to
psychoanalysis as a delusion and his
paper actually had some interesting
points to make he pointed out for
example that the Freudian tries to find
out about your past he delves because to
find out the past but the truth is that
we know from atomic theory that given
the current state of the automata and
the input you can determine the future
but even if you knew the input from the
current state you could not determine
the past it was another example and
probably the most important one was that
he said that that a circuit built that
the neurons had to have inhibition as
well as excitation you know he was
adding up and here you have to have both
positives and negatives and he could
prove that you must have that for the
this formal circuit without the
inhibition could not do this and at the
time that he said this the
neurophysiologist ship shook their head
now no we've never seen that inhibition
but he kept pressing them and so they
looked and they found it yeah yeah the
first sight of it that I heard of was a
neurophysiologist fetish in who said
that in the goldfish retina there is
this neuron that has many inputs and one
big fat one and the signal comes along
this big fat one
it stops it neuron cold mm-hmm that was
very nice in fact that that's enough
inhibition if all neurons had just that
it would be enough but then later they
found that no there really is excitation
and in
Bishan so how did this interest in the
brain then then color the rest of your
research moving forward so when I came
into McCulloch slab I I was accepted I I
was able to prove a theorem I was
accepted and then I would have having to
read all he wanted me to read how he was
accepted and then I at some point get
garnered the confidence to tell him I
really wanted to understand
consciousness mm-hmm and he and Walter
Pitts said no you will not yeah work on
consciousness and then waltrip it took
me over and said look you he G would has
to go through this thicker skull to get
to the what's generating signals we
simply can't do the experiments and
without the experiments we don't have
the data you need it that wasn't
completely true there were surgeons like
at the time who were opening up brains
you know to find where the epileptic
fits were coming from and they
discovered some some things but by and
large we could not we couldn't get the
data and so I was not allowed to look at
consciousness mm-hmm
which is it still bothers me because
even what I'm doing now is a very formal
model of the brain I it's not the real
brain it's a formal model and I think I
could have done it then too but I I was
not allowed to look at that problem I
see so what some was was was recursive
function theory then a natural
alternative were all bad it was yeah it
was a natural you have to understand
that at the time logic and recursive
function theory considered pretty
important yeah
Walter Pitts actually ran away from home
when he was 14 years old
founders so I said it's McCulloch and
Pitt's and Walter pitch ran away from
home found his way to Chicago 14-year
old and he was walking in the park and
met a guy named Burt and they started
chatting and talking and Burt turns out
to be Bertrand Russell yeah and so Burt
told him about this logician and in
Chicago that he should go see much like
my professor told me I should go see my
college and and so Walter read the work
that this person had done and went to
see him what's his name he was a
logician at at Chicago it escapes me but
it'll it'll come so Walter went to see
him and the logician whose name escapes
me now said describes it like this this
young man came to see me and he had a
copy of my book and he said that on
such-and-such a page he found something
that was not clear to him now you have
to understand that when I say that
something is not clear to me I mean it's
garbage so we opened the book to that
page and I read it and it was not clear
to me either
what Walter was really good because he
was the mathematician and he's the one
that essentially told me that anything
you want if you want to know you can get
from books
I guess nowadays the it would be
anything you want to know using Google
for it and get very few things that you
can't find very
whew and of course those things that you
can't find that research yes yeah
and so when did you when did you come up
with the blonde axioms for also like
complexity theory no so let's see so so
so that there was metallic but I did go
into mathematics and logic and refers to
function theory you know I could only
take one course at a time
mm-hmm this was unheard of the I mean
core students were expected to take
several courses and most of them took
two you know and even lenore when she
was a student at MIT she started off
with five but then dropped to four drop
to three my I I came at it the other way
around the minimum required to so I take
two and drop one and that way I could
actually get into something yeah and
it's in some ways is terrible because
there's all sorts of things I did not
learn but the stuff I learned I learned
pretty well mm-hmm and that was this
recursive function theory which this
logic and recursive function theory
which at that time I thought would be
the right mathematics for understanding
the brain yeah I I wouldn't suggest it
now not the right but at that time that
was what I did and so from that I did
this complexity theory and what's that
while he was still at MIT yes oh yeah
yeah that was first year PhD student I
see and then what brought you to
Berkeley Lenoir graduated yeah was one
thing but what really brought me a lot
fees odd to hear invited me to come and
that was wonderful
mmm that was wonderful well well brought
me here is I got a job
[Laughter]
yeah that was that was very nice and and
and and that was an electrical engineer
so going into an electrical engineering
department was the right thing for me I
liked that I never I my PhD was in math
but I never felt like a mathematician I
was an electrical engineer I still had
this okay
and so when I got to Berkeley in 81 you
had already started this new period with
number-theoretic now you know
cryptography and thinking about mental
okay
so this seemed like a new phase in your
in your thing so you you you know people
ask me or how I am how I teach my
students they don't seem to understand
that I'm learning from the students and
I mean that very seriously Gary Miller
was very was interested in number theory
and then it's applications and really
the idea of the complexity of these
number theoretic functions that's
something he knew about and he dictated
to Dana Anglin and Dana Anglin wrote it
up and that's how I got into it and I
found it very interesting I guess part
of what got me into it also is there was
this terrible thing that happened to me
that they made me the associate chairman
for computer science I tried to tell
them that I that's not a good thing
because I wouldn't be very good at it
but they insisted and and so I I was a
so as associate chairman I I made a
point every morning of spending one hour
on some but I like number theory mmm
they have to Gary Miller I spent an hour
on number theory and you know some days
I couldn't because the life of a
chairman can be very busy but
the less I did try to spend one hour and
I think that was the best thing I could
do I could completely switch over mm-hmm
so when when did you when did you stop
being chair I think it was 1980 okay
that's right and that that's when you
took this up more then I could switch
over to the cryptography and the
beautiful number theory that it uses
yeah yeah that that was very wonderful
mm-hm and it's also wonderful that Derek
lamer was a professor here in the math
department there were some people here
and you know Len Adleman had already
around that time or maybe a little later
a little later when the carp came out
with his np-complete problems and Len
Adleman began to show that there are
these number theoretic problems never
np-complete yeah that was a meteor a
little earlier than possibly yeah
sometime around then right but it was
really Gary Miller that you know that
got me into the number theory is that it
was wonderful because I loved the number
theory that's wonderful
great and I liked what came out of it
you know I I like this whole now this
whole idea of zero knowledge proof for
example yeah the idea that I can
convince you that a theorem is true in
such a way that you cannot turn around
and convince anybody else hmm
you know to a mathematician like Derek
Lam Ruiz that's crazy
you can't do that he was constantly
trying to teach me what a proof is but
of course I was a logician I knew what a
proof was but this was wonderful concept
wonderful notion you know so I really
like that and I guess that was your
analysis work that Sylvia McCauley and
Chafee Goldwasser came up with the
definition for it and that again an
example where I'm learning from the
student
Sylvio told me that yes I had always
said you know the theorems and the
proofs are the important thing
so you said no it's the definitions that
are important it's the definitions and
he has made a point of have getting good
definitions that have worked yeah so
even you know this the whole notion of
zero knowledge proof you know it sort of
sounds like the proof is convincing you
that a third theory is true but giving
you no other information that's what it
is that's not true there's not true I
mean you do get other information if I
give you a zero knowledge proof there's
a certain amount of talking that we have
to do and by the time you're done not
only are you convinced it's true but you
also have a bound on the length of the
truth and so you have some information
yeah about it
how long the proof is that's useful and
you also have some more information like
the fact that I know it yeah so what I
learned from this was you know you
define something like zero knowledge
proof you you make a definition and then
you study it and it's making the
definition is it's really the important
thing getting it clear right so that I
learned from Sylvia that was a very
special time here in Berkeley you know
this I mean this this whole exploration
that you started and then Sylvia and
Jaffe give all these other other
students around it was quite a quite a
wonderful Taylor's are wonderful it was
a very wonderful time yeah and and now
you're often you know another adventure
which is it seems really completely
open-ended and now I'm back to what I
really wanted yeah a little more about
it you know how how ambitious are you
about it and you know what what would it
mean to you know again is there is there
so you talked about getting the right
definitions so I that's what I want I
want Solon this is work that Lenore and
I do together
mm-hmm you know in cryptography the way
you work is usually done is one person
comes up with algorithms and the other
one breaks very important to have
somebody to talk to yes on the other
side of the fence and so Lenore and I
are doing things like that we and I and
remembering what Sylvia taught me I
decided look like I can't go and do I
can't go into brains I'm not gonna I'm
not a surgeon I'm not going to use that
from our I what I'm I'm a theoretical
computer scientist what can I do I can
create a formal model to try to
understand consciousness and some people
like John Anderson at Carnegie Mellon
will tell me you can't make a simple
mock I wouldn't after simple modeling
the brain is very complicated it's got
all sorts of stuff it's all sorts of
stuff that it pasted and glued together
you can't do this and Lenore's responds
to John Anderson is you don't understand
we want a simple model that we can
understand that we can prove theorems
about and where we can make our
definitions and once we've done this
you'll be able to tell this model with
any good or not you'll be able to tell
from whether or not the the definitions
are good whether or not they concur you
know they agree with what we think and
so this has already started because so I
without going into the definition of
this formal model one of the things that
comes out of it is a definition of
consciousness that's part of what comes
out of the model and another specific
thing is the notion of a chunk so the
psychologists had there was a George
Miller who defined who talked about
chunking for the first time he said our
working memory can hold at most seven
plus or minus two chunks
he never defined chunk yeah so what's a
chunk when this paper he said well a
chunk is like a digit or a letter or a
word it can be a word and actually if
you know a poem it could even be a poem
mm-hmm he didn't define it but from the
model it becomes very clear that a chunk
is a pointer it's just a pointer to that
letter that digit that poem you know we
all learn the alphabet abcdefg yeah it's
a pointer to the start of that and once
we are there we can reel it off so I'm
kind of proud of that then we have at
least in the formal model the definition
for what a chunk is mm-hmm and you can
have in most seven plus or minus two
chunks and you know in the model it's a
constant number yeah so how far you know
so you you're trying to pin down this
model how far are we yeah and and what
you know what do you do to pin it down
so obviously you know you're looking at
you're trying to fill in this model but
you have you have a lot of
considerations in mind you know you're
looking at a lot of things and then
saying in order for these things to be
true what should this model look like
and you know say you you you you have a
yeah I'm taking a while I mean is I
think we started off with something that
was a bit too complicated we put into it
what we felt would be enough to be able
to define consciousness and chunk and
other concepts like that and then part
of our time has been getting rid of oh I
don't need this oh I don't need that so
if you look at my talks for a couple
years ago there are more complicated
models and we've been able to get it
down to something that I think it's
close to manageable
am i there you know I I'm particularly
interested in trying to understand the
agony of pain mmm the fact that when we
tear a ligament we feel this tremendous
pain that's my interest Lenoir on the
other hand is really interested in joy
the joy that you get when you hear
beautiful piece of music or the you know
the joy of first love these are things
that are it's hard to imagine a robot
being able to feel these things and so
my interest is to really be able to get
at these feelings what is it in us
that's causing these feelings and she's
trying a pain and cheese into trying to
get to the answer the question what is
it that's causing these feelings of joy
and you are you doing this as a
heuristic as as a machine model that you
know how does the brain keep track of
this and why does it keep track of it
and so in our model we do have an
explanation for how pain is generated
I'm not happy with the explanation for
joy mm-hmm but we have an explanation
for pain and whether or not this is
right very much depends on whether it
agrees with what with these examples
that we find for examining pain or
really feeling the agony of pain doctors
right now don't know how to tell they
have these phases zero very happy ten
tears where's your pain and you know
that you're hoping to be able to get
from fMRI and other such things some
notion of how much pain you have but so
far that hasn't worked they don't have a
good way to tell and when somebody comes
into the doctor's office and says I have
a pain in my shoulder the doctor doesn't
know this he really have that pain
or if he wanting just to get the pill so
he can sell them on the street right and
one of the things that I think a good
definition a good understanding will
give us I'm hoping for is a way to tell
distinguish between the one and the
other and the reason you want to
distinguish is because presumably
because the real thing is a is a better
heuristic for going through life that
that somehow it makes a difference
whether it's simulated or not it makes a
difference right and that's a beautiful
thing too that I can you point that to a
disorder that some people have called
pain has been boliya where a person
who's born with.this knows about the
pain knows that the shoulder hurts knows
maybe it's exactly where how much
pressure everything that you would know
but isn't doesn't suffer mm-hm
doesn't suffer and the kids that are
born with this disorder rarely live past
the age of three you need to actually be
feel that pain in order to do the right
thing and it's it's not is it that it's
not just that the kids don't live past
it but even if they got to a to a
greater age where they could be
cognitively more in with no-english
intended and then would they would they
then would it still not be effective
just knowing that that that you know you
feel pain it was good enough to navigate
through life it really has to be you
need something more and need something
more so the example is this beautiful
girl was paying as Boleo you see
pictures of her when she's born she's
beautiful and the parents really wanted
her to live by the age of three they had
to remove all of her teeth because she
was biting her tongue and her lips and
terrible and by the age of seven she
understood the importance of pain and
her parents had told her you know when
you're when you notice that pain
because you're painting a symbolic dunno
about it they know it when you notice it
you must stop what you're doing and come
come home and and deal with it properly
and so this girl was out playing ball
and her leg must have gone into a hole
in the ground and she broke the leg and
she knew she had broken the leg and she
knew that her parents made the point
that she must go home but she was having
fun and so now when you see pictures of
her you see one leg is shorter than the
other
I know stories of elite athletes who've
played on through injuries but with poor
you know with poor into that those
stories eventually yeah but but but
that's a good point so eventually you
know once once you have you know now
that you are converging on a model what
would you hope to do next with this
model of the brain and consciousness or
this aspect of it for pain we will take
take it next yeah so that's a very good
question so one thing that comes out of
this is the question of what do you need
in order to be conscious hmm
what sort of so the model has that
you're conscious of just a very small
amount of stuff the stuff and working
memory and that your long-term memory is
all of these processors that are doing
work for you and that yeah you really
not caught you have no idea of how they
work through consciousness maybe you can
ask a slightly different question
you know what happened boom yeah yeah
just to get a slightly different
question so so you know at some level
one of the one of the questions about
consciousness
one could ask is why why consciousness
you know what what purpose does it serve
so does that is that the starting point
of your model or is it something that
that would get eliminated as a
consequence of the model yeah no I think
I think
the real thing hmm and the intent of the
model is to be able to explain it as
well as to explain these emotions that
we have and a lot of what so this gets
back to what I was trying to say a lot
of what comes out of this is you can ask
yourself what do you need to have in
order to be conscious do you need to
feel pain no because they're people that
don't feel pain yeah and that are
conscious do you need to be able to
speak no because they're people that
don't speak and Helen Keller could
neither see nor hear and you she was
conscious so you don't need these so you
know you try to cut back to what you
need there's a huge piece of our brain
is the cerebellum it's got half the
neurons in our brain half and some
people are born without a cerebellum and
they are conscious they without the
cerebellum it's they learn to walk but
it takes them longer and they can't play
the violin and there are many things
that they can't do that require fine
tuning but they are absolutely conscious
preconscious
talking about you know one of the so
part of what we do is what do you
absolutely need to have in order to be
conscious and we can point to one thing
after another that you don't need in
order to be conscious and we've come up
with three things there I'm sure there
many more but three important things
that you need for consciousness and one
of them is a model of yourself the way
to distinguish yourself from the rest of
the world it seems to be an important
part of this and people who lose that
are in some sense beginning to lose
consciousness what was that the reason
for going into recursive functions here
that self-aware wonderful thank you well
I'd good point I mean it's nice have a
theorem that a Turing machine can on the
blank tape print out a copy of it so
yeah that's yeah so that's one of the
things there's another thing which is
inner speech so I've spoken to people
who are mute they their own here they
don't speak but they have sign language
and they tell me that they speak to
themselves in their using in their brain
using sign language goodness yes mm-hmm
I was very nice but yeah they could tell
me that for those two things and there
is another thing which I'm I call
motivation where that there should be
something you want to do desire and the
energy to do it so those are the three
things that so far we've decided are
really essential and one of the nice
things is that the the psychologist has
a test for consciousness which you who
knows how good it is but I discovered
after we had come up with these three
things that wow their test does reflect
these
well the mirror test the the you you you
dab their forehead with some paint they
don't see it until they get to a mirror
and they see it on them and they try to
take it off their forehead and that's
the mirror test and for the psychologist
it's the mirror test which determines
whether or not they are self-aware
at the very least self-aware yeah and
it's not a very good test because you
know a gorilla does not pass the mirror
test because a gorilla will not look
another gorilla on the eye this is a
very and dogs don't really respond so
much to mirrors but the test has been
modified so it's a and a smell test yeah
there is now relatively recently a kind
of smell test where you see that the dog
recognizes its own odor and
distinguishes it from others and it's
very nice and it gives you a sense of
how very well the the sorts of animals
that can have this self-awareness
there's now been found that there are
some ants that happen I think they're
near mica amps three species of Mir mica
you paint the plate on the front and you
they you let them walk past the mirror
and once they see it Wow and you see the
ant can do something we can't do it'll
walk up on the mirror to look at itself
carefully it does not try to take the
paint off the ants in there it
recognizes that it's on itself and then
you see it you know
self and rubbing against the sides of
the mirror to try to get to try to room
very interesting and the same thing is
true with a fish there's a fish called
the cleaner wrasse which for various
reasons was believed to be a good
subject for this and it to it you can
paint it and it will see it and will try
to get rid of the paint on itself not in
the mirror not on some other fish just
on itself
ya know just switching topics you know
how does it back to be back in birthday
it's been it's been a while it's nice
yeah yeah but given that you're you know
have you ever thought about you know
given the this very creative period you
had here in the 80s you know it's and
now that you have in part on this big
project of right now we're coming back
and which is really important to me and
yeah well you know Berkeley is nice
fortunately Carnegie Mellon was very
nice too because trying to you Mel in
the head you you know Alan Perlis we
ended our with Lenore's first took the
first computer science country given on
the planet from Alan Perlis you know and
they had a Newell Alan Newell and they
have John Anderson these are the people
that you know cognitive science
psychologists that really know about
this stuff so it's very nice being there
and working on this and being back in
Berkeley is also of course very nice
very well it's really wonderful to have
you back you know for you know I always
of course you know when I came here you
know you were a big part of the of the
CS here and all of the environment and I
always think of it as you you as a part
of the scene yeah so it's really thank
you wonderful to have you
care and no nitwit thank you
[Music]